there are many people that believe that
a near-death experience is just the
brain dying that's producing some
chemical that's producing hallucinations
hey friends Laci green here for dnews
near-death experiences have been
described by people across the world who
came or thought they were coming within
an inch of their life a new study has
been published by the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences on NDEs the
study was done on rats and found that
after cardiac arrest there's this crazy
spike in neural activity the lead author
says that if anything the brain is much
more active during the dying process and
even the waking state so essentially the
neurons going to overdrive as death sets
in causing the brain to go haywire in a
predictable way you warmth bright light
floating etc I'm floating up into the
sky and there is an explosion of light
and color and then I was just shot
backwards at an incredible speed
everything just went black and I just
felt this backwards momentum while I
feel like I'm being pressed in from all
sides in that void there was a voice and
the voice said hey Quinn I'm out here
with you too right so yeah this is what
unconditional love feels like love is
the only thing that's real I'm the only
thing that's real you need to go tell
everybody that and I arrived in this
really incredibly beautiful Valley it
was just bright as anything it was so
vivid as the colors were just
spectacular I've never seen anything
like it and outside the house was my mum
and my dog butch who died about 10 years
ago and I run up to my mom and I give
her a big hug I'm like I love you mommy
she's like I love you too and then I can
feel myself getting pulled back into my
body and also as I'm getting pulled I'm
like no no no I remember saying no no
and it's as though this place is
saturated in meaning and beauty and
significance and love in a way that is
truly impossible to put into words for
me there's this subjective feeling that
was just undeniable that this is a
divine realm I shot out in the middle of
this town and I'm standing on the street
that I don't recognize and almost the
moments that I you know start looking
around a friend of mine pops into my
head he's a guy that used to be in a
band used to play guitar with me a few
years ago and cancer took him a couple
years back and the moment that I thought
about him
here he comes walking down the street
you look just the same as he used to
this is more so of a knowing son knew
what this voice voice all right new like
I'm familiar with it and it was God it
was the voice of God that spoke to me
and said hey yo this is unconditional
love no matter how far you think you've
gone I'm still right there with you so
how do you feel about scientists saying
that these experiences are nothing but
chemical reactions in the brain and
there's no spiritual aspect to it at all
you may be surprised I'm going to show
you the context of these experiences
today's videos going to be about astral
projection in this video I'm going to be
sharing 10 lessons that I learned from
taking DMT dimethyltryptamine for those
of you who may not know DMT is one of
the most powerful psychedelic substances
that we know of today I just wanted to
share one of my most recent projections
with you all welcome back to that God
power Channel just a channel where we're
going to unlock the god power that's
laying dormant inside of you but first
today I want to talk about something
that was really special and
life-changing for me and DMT is what I'm
talking about dimethyltryptamine is what
it's called
so I've smoked DMT about four or five
times I take two giant hits and I'm
instantly beamed out of my body I
recently made an entire video about how
to have a mystical experience it can
to the spirit realm using psychedelic
substances DMT and you saw the title
it's about God the Tribune of God is
here within all of us he's watching
everybody every bit of
there's an aisle on you all the time you
know and any totally you know don't stop
these journeys don't stop your
enlightenment on these journeys now
you've reached the kingdom of the gates
and you took the path to walk through
these doors now it's time to learn and
teach and maybe enlighten others to do
the same I think my my lesson that I
learned from this just half experiences
don't don't forget the pain and welcome
new pain because as soon as pain hits
you there's love right after it no
matter wife I took two really big hits
and immediately I could tell something
was different I don't feel my body and
I'll feel the world that I an align on
the bed in I'm at this new world as it's
been formed first it's really really
fast I'm just whizzing through this
tunnel and I keep thinking I'm just
gonna pop out but I don't eventually a
tunnel just gets wider and wider and
wider until it opens up into this big
team and the first thing I see is
another ball of light off in the
distance and I go holy I remember you
from back before I was a human so as you
can see none of the clips that you saw
were actually near-death experiences
they were either new-age astral
projection rectus or a trip from smoking
DMT characteristics they both have in
common are leaving the body going
towards a bright white light and even
meeting dead family members or God
himself or herself we can see how
deceptive this can be so how can we
trust any near-death experience
I see people buying into these
near-death experiences because it's just
such a fascinating experience that no
one could even imagine but I believe
there is a connection between drugs and
the spiritual world in Revelation 18
verse 23 it says for by thy sorceries
were all nations deceived that word
sorcery is the greek word pharmakeia
where we get our word pharmacy from and
I do believe that tampering with
pharmakeia or sorcery is an
open invitation for Satan and demons to
deceive people
so now listen to these near-death
experiences and see if there's any
common attribute between them then I
found myself leave the body I then
started to see this light that was
incredibly bright he perceived the time
my grandma how well he was being
operated on he floated out of his body
he saw them operating on him and he
floated four floors how he floated up up
up and how the roof of the hospital
opened up and he floated up past the
universe into the sky up into the most
beautiful beautiful environment that's
when I got to see heaven would you left
your body you didn't die left your body
yeah um I could look down and I could
see my body and then I could see my mom
in one room and she was on the phone
talking and praying then my dad was in
another room and he was praying and
yelling at the same time I was aware of
everything that was going on around me I
was aware of what everyone was doing my
family and how distressed they were I
was aware of what the doctors were doing
in the hospital when I was in that realm
I was given a choice of whether to come
back into physical life or not it
literally went from inside my body and
when I shut my eyes I was then just the
next second I was up on the ceiling
looking down at the entire room the
feeling like nothing she'd ever known
there was this feeling of a presence
that was next to me it felt like it was
God it felt so loving and so accepting
sherry was dead for 90 minutes but
miraculously came back to life and now
has a profound near-death experience to
share and I remember my body just
floating and like this white space
and I felt as light as a feather I felt
free I literally was in a whole other
realm so I wasn't I was no longer in the
physical hospital room I was completely
in another realm I actually felt
connected to my family on the other side
and I felt connected to the heavens sort
of like passing out except you pass it's
just a lot of white light and you see
people that have passed on and they
talked to you and and then you pop right
back into your body and you're awake
uh-huh and you have a I had an
incredible sense of well-being in a
sense that it's just so near it's not a
far away or scary thing he was down for
close to 45 minutes during which time he
claims he traveled beyond this world and
back oh he was telling me that he loved
me and that he'd seen the light and that
he had seen my mom and my dad and I lost
it at that point in time because I just
lost my mom the week after burying his
mother-in-law notice most if not all
near-death experiences happen in a
hospital while someone has pumped full
of pharmaceutical drugs
I believe these visions that patients
are experiencing are a deception and
here's why
because John 3:13 says and no man hath
ascended up to heaven but he that came
down from heaven even the Son of Man
which is in heaven see the Bible tells
us that when we die we will be asleep in
Jesus and when Christ comes back the
dead in Christ shall rise first put on
immortality and be caught up to meet the
Lord in the air all of God's people will
get to witness going to heaven at one
time what an exciting experience it'll
be if you're interested in learning more
about this topic click the note card
above right now
you